el lugar de Ucrania está en la otan el
secretario general de la organización
del tratado del Atlántico Norte James
toltenberg aterrizó en kiev de manera
sorpresiva en lo que es su primera
visita al país desde el inicio de la
guerra stoltenberg se reunió con el
presidente ucraniano voló y mirt
selenski mismo que urgió de nueva cuenta
al jefe de la alianza a definir cuando
es que Ucrania recibiría una propuesta
formal para unirse a la otan
necesitamos algo más allá de nuestra
relación actual apreciamos mucho la
ayuda militar de los países de la otan
pero también Queremos saber cuándo
Ucrania será miembro de la otan de igual
manera queremos garantías de seguridad
en Nuestro camino hacia la integración
en la otan
hasta el momento stoltenberg había sido
cuidadoso en declarar sobre la posible
membresía de Ucrania la otan fue vocal
al expresar que la alianza está
dispuesta a ofrecerle un lugar a kiev
leds permítanme ser claro el lugar que
le corresponde a Ucrania está en la
familia euroatlántica el lugar que le
corresponde a Ucrania está en la otan y
con el tiempo nuestro apoyo le ayudará a
hacer lo posible
el kremlin ha expresado varias veces su
rechazo al ingreso de Ucrania en la otan
Aunque en el marco de la Cumbre de vilna
en julio la membresía ucraniana podría
estar más cerca que nunca